KARIM LAKHANI: So tell
us what Flagship does?
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Yeah.
So Flagship is first and foremost
a life science innovation company.
We have our own way by which we
innovate, which I'll tell you about.
Once we come up with something
that's worth taking forward,
we form a company to take that forward.
And so we also have to
figure out how to do
venture creation in a systematic way.
We have our own capital that
we deploy into these companies
to help them grow for the
first two, three years.
So up until then they operate as
wholly owned pieces of Flagship.
And then we spin them out.
And we spin them out, and for the first
time, additional capital comes in.
But by that time, the culture,
the senior leadership team,
the early proof of concept, the early
kind of customer or partner traction
is there.
And it looks like a company ready to
eventually live its life on its own.
So we're not interested in building
kind of subsidiaries, open-endedly.
Every single thing we do ends up
becoming a company or nothing.
So we've become kind of a creator of
companies around internal innovations.
Now sometimes these innovations
draw from external science.
And I can describe that.
But we're not only trying to
find science and then find what
to do with it and create companies.
That's become in vogue
for the last few years.
We've been doing this for 18 years.
But we've ended up in a place
where we think the sustainable
way to do this is to have your own
innovation capacity, your own company
creation capacity, initial growth, and
then the companies have the wherewithal
to grow and compete and thrive.
KARIM LAKHANI: That's fascinating.
So walk us through one
example of a company
that you guys have given
birth to from the start
to it's leaving the Flagship fold.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: There are many.
I think we've been
involved in doing about 50
of these that are based on
internally developed science.
And there's a whole bunch more
that also include external.
But I'd say one of the
internally developed ones
that just recently went public, I
can give as an example is Moderna.
So Moderna was-- and I'll tell you.
We have this fairly, let's
say, prescribed process.
Which the way people think about
entrepreneurship and innovation,
especially breakthrough
innovation, is that it is unruly.
It is chaotic.
It is inspired.
KARIM LAKHANI: Serendipity!
NOUBAR AFEYAN: In my view,
it's none of those things.
KARIM LAKHANI: None of those?
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Absolutely
none of those things.
I have a completely
contrarian view of that.
And I've done it enough times
in enough different fields
that I think, frankly, just
to be a little controversial,
I think that's an illusion.
In other words, I think that because
people haven't done that thing before,
it's exciting and unexpected to them.
But actually, pretty quickly, it
looks like just another version
of what came before them.
Because the historians come
and say, well, you know,
before there was the
iPad, there was the iPod.
And before that, there was
the Walkman, et cetera.
And also, when you look at it that way,
you go, well, why were you surprised?
And that's when you realize that
these things are just evolving.
And I'll give you an example
in this company called Moderna.
But before that, I'll
tell you that underlying
how we think you can
do this systematically
is the notion that breakthroughs
aren't made by people.
They emerge.
And the most understood,
not well understood,
but understood version of emergence
that we know about is evolution.
Which is that if you do
variation, iteration, selection
and iteration systematically,
the winners will emerge.
And when they do, they
will look surprising.
But actually, they're the
result of that process.
They're not some inspired thought that
has nothing to do with that process.
So hold that thought as I give examples.
They'll all be examples of that.
And that actually does cause
one to think differently
about being possessive about all these
companies and all these innovations.
We're not.
We don't go around
saying we invented this.
We may file a patent
and get an invention.
But where these ideas come
from are very emergent.
So in Moderna's case,
talking about emergence,
we understood by following the
various scientific advances
that people were playing around with
converting fibroblast cells into what's
called induced pluripotent stem cells.
Somebody won a Nobel
Prize recently for this.
These are called Yamanaka factor.
So it turns out that if you
take differentiated cells,
and you introduce a couple, three
different proteins, four of them
specifically, these cells
can de-differentiate and look
like what came before them, stem cells.
They're not normal stem cells.
But they're close to being stem cells.
And so why do that?
Because then you could differentiate
it and make other cells.
So that was the general field.
And in that field, there have been some
people, particularly at UPenn and then,
more recently, at
Children's Hospital here
in Boston, who had been playing
around with using what's
called mRNA, messenger RNA,
to use these to go into cells
and express these proteins.
Why had they done that?
Because it turns out this
mRNA, they could actually
get a better transformation
of these cells.
And so we were aware of this work.
And we started asking kind
of just what if questions.
KARIM LAKHANI: So your team
is reading scientific papers.
It's in the air.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: In this
case, yeah, exactly.
And we do this all the time.
And basically, we're--
KARIM LAKHANI: You're in the midst
of this flow of knowledge being used.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: It's not about reading
papers for us as much as just, I mean,
we are talking to lots of people
about lots of different things.
Or somebody says, hey, by the way,
you know, I just saw this data.
And then we actually
read papers in hindsight.
In other words, we read papers
once we have an idea of what to do,
as opposed to read papers
to get an idea per se.
The signal to noise
in papers is gigantic.
If you sit there and read
1,000 papers, and that
gives you three ideas,
hard to do anything else.
So I'm sure that can be done, too.
But that's not the way we approach it.
Anyway, so long story short, we
started wondering, for lots of reasons
that I can't almost reproduce
because you'd have to go back to 2010
in the summer and whatever else
was being thought of at the time.
So understand, by that
time, we had about 20 people
that were doing this type of activity
in various combinations for a living.
And so it's important.
Because these ideas kind of
get mixed and moved around.
This is not-- one person thinking
deeply is not going to get there.
So we start asking,
can you think about--
we said why is there no
drug that is based on mRNA?
Now if you go back 10
years, drugs were made out
of proteins and small molecules.
There had been an effort to
use viruses to introduce genes
into the body called gene therapy.
And a person had died early on and
that whole field was shut down.
And there really was no other variation
to proteins or small molecules.
And there've been some efforts to
try to make, not to get too detailed,
but other small DNA, RNA molecules,
antisense, what's called.
And we were aware of all this.
But we're thinking, why don't people
actually use this microRNA molecule?
And that's just a thought experiment.
And you can go and answer that question.
KARIM LAKHANI: So you
raised the problem?
NOUBAR AFEYAN: You raise--
you don't say, you know,
initially, we don't start with,
we need to cure melanoma.
We don't start it from what good is
this mRNA that can transform cells.
Because it's not good for
anything other than that.
But we just kind of
abstract it and said,
is there a combination of
a solution and a problem
that we can identify
simultaneously around this space?
And if there isn't one, then we move on.
And in this case, that's
part of our methodology.
In this case, what we concluded was
that people had tried and failed
10 years earlier.
We understood why they tried and failed.
We realized that there
was no obvious fix to it.
But there was a direction of fixing
that you could modify chemically
some of these RNA molecules.
And they at least hinted
that if you kept doing that,
there may be better ways.
We had no proof.
There was no academic literature
that said this can be done.
Now we could have waited for that.
But we probably would
have been five, six years.
Because now, there is
academic papers from which
we could have started companies.
But our whole thing is to almost
mine this science of the future
to try to solve problems of today
versus mine the science of today
to solve problems of the future.
And that is exactly backwards.
And it's not any better.
It's just that you look
at the world differently.
So publications give you
evidence for what you want to do.
But that's not why they
publish those things.
They were thinking of
a very different thing.
You know what I'm saying?
So in that regard, that's a little bit.
So in Moderna's case, we identified--
well, the other thing that we do,
a very integral part of what we do
is that we don't do this in a vacuum.
So we go out and talk to
people about our hypotheses.
These are not--
KARIM LAKHANI: You're not afraid
of people taking your ideas?
NOUBAR AFEYAN: No.
And I'll tell you why.
So we use, in order to try to create
an evolution-- so we're trying
to create an evolutionary environment.
How do you do that?
The scientific method uses
hypotheses and experimentation.
So we actually do the same thing.
We create value hypotheses.
We basically say, I will take an mRNA
molecule, formulate it with this agent,
stick it into muscle.
Use muscle-- none of it is true.
None of it's been done before.
But it's just a starting point.
We then go with that
to a handful of folks
that are both experts and nonexperts
in the field, super important thing
if you're going to
practice this kind of work
is that experts actually
are not the people who
are going to give you an idea of how
to do things dramatically differently,
because they became experts
by already doing something
dramatically differently.
And now they're defending
their territory.
So if you go to talk to somebody
and say, can this be done out here?
Most people we talk to, they can tell
you precisely why it can't be done,
which is really valuable from a
selection pressure standpoint.
But not the source of kind of-- and
here is a completely different way.
So other people, though,
who don't have expertise,
but have interesting creativity-- so
what we do is we take our hypotheses,
and it's never one.
Because one of the
things we've learned is
that if you start with
one starting point,
you only locally search
the space around it.
So we sample multiple different points.
So it might be how about mRNA as a way
to make more proteins in a fermenter?
So around the theme, we come up
with totally different variables
we try to identify.
And then we put a starting point.
And then we start talking.
And then what's been interesting and a
great learning exercise over the years
that we've seen is that if you
go to somebody with a bad idea,
but you actually present
it in a precise way,
they will tell you why it's a bad idea.
And in that transaction,
something happens.
They feel smarter.
KARIM LAKHANI: Yes.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: And you
get selection pressure.
And so the way our process
works is that we actually
do this with multiple people.
So when you said, aren't you afraid
they're going to take your idea?
What are they taking?
We just made it up.
There's zero fact to
it, literally zero fact.
KARIM LAKHANI: Just
imagining a hypothesis?
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Exactly.
We're just a hypothesis.
And they know it.
Because then they tell us,
what proof do you have?
I say none.
So then, they still engage.
Because when we talk to these folks,
and this is what we're known for,
we create a bit of an expert-free zone
in the sense that-- you see, look.
These scientists and here we are
at Harvard and MIT, Stanford,
these people go to the
meetings of their fields.
And they cannot say something that
does not seem unbelievably smart
and reasonable.
Actually, I'll make the point.
Let me caveat.
Reasonableness, in my view, is
like the gravitational force
that keeps innovation from happening.
Because people enforce reasonableness
in the scientific world
on what you are allowed to say.
You go publish something
in the literature that's
not reasonable to the
reviewers, you can't publish.
KARIM LAKHANI: You're killed.
I've done a whole study on that.
NOUBAR AFEYAN: Right.
So ask yourself the
question, why is it that we
think that the only innovations worth
working on start their life reasonably?
In fact, I can show you many
innovations that are now,
you know, accepted as real,
transformative things.
Every one of them started
life unreasonably.
And yet, we go look for
them in reasonable places
by reasonable people who are using
reasonableness filters to kill them.
So because we knew that, this was
not the first thing I had done,
we kind of say, look, let's just
forget reasonableness for a second.
Just think with us.
And they tell us bad idea.
Somebody in Japan had tried it.
The experiment won't work.
And we keep tweaking and
tweaking and tweaking.
This is different than you
hear a lot in Silicon Valley
speak, kind of a pivoting.
This is not pivoting.
Evolution is the master pivot.
It's, like, nonstop pivoting.
There's nothing to pivot from and to.
You're just adapting and surviving.
So that mindset is super important.
Now what happens is,
over time, things emerge.
Or they don't.
But they emerge where the
next person you talk to,
they can't find fault with it.
You know that because
it frustrates them.
And then they start telling you,
well, do you have any proof?
You go, no, no, no.
I just made this up.
It's just that we've been-- anyway.
And then that point is when we
go into a lab for the first time.
And then and only then
do we test the idea.
Now you can't test it fully.
You can't test it, because
it takes years and years.
And one of the expertise
we've developed over the years
is how to figure out what to test first.
And in life science, you can't use
these words, killer experiment.
Because you know, life sciences, kill.
But you want to do the
killer experiment early.
And so figuring out what's the killer
experiment, or two or three or four,
that if it doesn't fail allows you
to go forward, that's the trick.
And we do that in our shops.
And in Moderna's case, we spent
a couple of million dollars,
about six months doing
a set of key things
but for which we would
not have proceeded.
So we knew the idea had morphed and
evolved and had some resilience to it.
We went into labs and
asked specific questions.
Once we saw that actually some of
the things we were hypothesizing
could be done partially,
we then decided, OK.
Let's form the best
economic value creation
engine known to mankind,
which is a startup in my view.
I'm biased.
And then we deploy that startup
to go after that value pool
in as many different ways as we can.